why hey rich how you doing
boy
can you hear me all right yeah what do
you got for me tonight so i've been
spinning plates um i've got kind of uh
like a little hiccup thing that's been
going on all right what's going down
basically
a lot of i'm finding like a lot of these
girls are getting kind of upset uh like
when i'm not answering my phone or uh
like when i'm hanging out with these
other girls you know and they just
they're getting kind of upset that and
they think something's going on and i
don't want to just like outright tell
them that
you know i'm hanging out with this other
chick if that makes sense so
your thoughts work okay so when they get
upset what do you mean like what do they
do give me uh give me a little bit of a
example well just the other night i had
one freak out on me because i didn't
text her all night not really freak out
but you know she was
she was pretty upset
so so how long have you been dating this
one like how long has she been a plate
not very long maybe like a month or two
and i basically told her without being
too much of uh
an a-hole like
well i kind of lied i told her i was uh
literally just drinking and watching
netflix and then look at my phone but
really i was on a date with someone else
yeah i wouldn't
i mean i wouldn't do that because
when you spin plates you want them to
understand covertly that they're not the
only one but you don't want to overtly
state hey i was with nancy and i
rearranged her guts on on thursday night
okay you're not getting yeah and i've
read your book and everything and i saw
that you don't want to like outright say
anything right so that's why i didn't do
that but i think i might have uh kind of
screwed up there but no no no no no no
you didn't do anything wrong see
the thing that you did wrong here is
that you care too much about her opinion
mm-hmm okay you've only been dating this
chick for what three four weeks you said
yeah something like that i've got
probably a four or five that i go on
dates with here and there so okay and
and how old are you
i am 23. okay so you're a young guy
sewing some wild oats checking out some
options figuring out life i hope you're
chasing excellence more than you're
chasing women though oh of course of
course good so so i mean these girls
that you got you know got a rotation
like women want see women are strange
creatures dude they're they're strange
they they want a guy that other women
want
other other women have to like you if if
other women don't like you
they just they just dry up dude man
they're just not into you
you know they're going to be distant
they're going to start moving away so
they so they have to see how other women
respond to you
like even even if you go to a restaurant
and you walk in with this girl and then
you know the greeter
she's hot she's wearing a black dress
all the right stuff on she walks you to
the table and she kind of smiles at you
or says you know i really like your
shirt or something like that and walks
away
that's great for you you want that right
because then in her lizard hiding brain
she's looking at that interaction going
holy [ __ ] that girl wants him right i
better make sure that i behave
yeah that's why spinning plates is
a good strategy especially for young
guys especially for divorce guys like
it's a great strategy to sort of like
you know get your head around the way
women are going to respond so the first
thing you're doing wrong is you're
caring too much about what she thinks of
you spending your time not with her
she's not your girlfriend she's not your
wife she's not your mom you don't know
her [ __ ] that's why i gladly told her
you know i told her well i told you that
i lied so i said i was like if i want to
be a degenerate one night and just drink
myself to sleep like
why what's the problem or your
girlfriend that's basically or or you
just say you know if i want to be at
a degenerate on wednesday night
leave me be i'll see you on friday make
sure you wear that black dress that i
like
and then you just kind of like move past
it right yeah you don't have to dance
around it or explain yourself or a paul
guys apologize for far too much stuff
today no i know and i'm not saying that
you did but but what i'm saying is guys
love to apologize for their behavior for
hurting you know for you know for her
feelings and the truth matter is is you
have to care a lot less about this [ __ ]
you know my energy my um chapter in the
book about managing your [ __ ] for
things that are truly [ __ ] worthy
this is not [ __ ] worthy like this like
you know
if this were to happen to me i'd just be
like yeah i was being a degenerate so
i'll see you friday night make sure you
wear that black dress i like sort of
thing you just kind of move past it
that's what that's what a muse mastery
is it's just kind of like
whatever you just kind of laugh it off
and you kind of roll past it sort of
thing that's all it is so you don't let
it get to you you know you keep doing
what you're doing and again um the only
time you're gonna have a conversation
about
getting into a ltr which you really
shouldn't at your age right because
you're a young guy yeah i'm not looking
for that right now yeah so it's like you
know and if she brings it up say hey you
know what why
i really like you i don't want you
seeing anybody else you know uh like
where do we stand then that's where you
just tell her the truth and say you know
hey dig your vibe too really had a you
know been having a great time
and i'm happy to continue doing that you
know if that's the way that you feel but
i'm not going to be sexually monogamous
with you so you're just going to have to
be okay with that you're going to be
okay with sharing me a little bit
i'm not going to i'm not going to
embarrass you i'm not going to bring a
disease home you know none of that
stuff's going to happen yeah that's it
but pretty much even if they asked don't
don't tell them i was rearranging
nancy's guts the other night nope no all
right got it it's it's you know it's
only when she wants to have the where do
we stand talk it's like you know you're
at the front door and you're seeing her
off she's like well hold on a sec why
where do we stand you know because we've
been seeing each other for four weeks
and
you know i feel like i want to see you
more and you know i really like you and
you know i want you to meet my dog and
all that kind of [ __ ] you start kind of
getting into those conversations if it's
appropriate like it's three six months
down the road not three weeks down the
road but if it's at an appropriate time
and you want to entertain that which i
really don't think that you should at
your age again you know you shouldn't
really be getting into an ltr right now
but if that's something that you want to
do that's basically how you handle it
gotcha all right i appreciate it yeah
all right man thanks buddy hey guys i
really hope that you enjoyed that short
clip if you did consider supporting the
creation of content by checking out my
supplement line pinned in the top
comment below of this video in the
comments there's a link to the unplugged
alpha dot com forward slash shop when
you click through you'll be able to land
over here and the entire lineup is
broken down by category that it performs
best in estrogen metabolism fat burning
your foundational essentials for health
immune health performance and
testosterone support if you check out
with coupon code alpha 10 you'll get 10
off on your first order there's also the
option to use the subscribe and save
model where regular shipments will be
sent over to you on a regular basis and
that gives you a little bit of a
discount and your supplement facts are
always broken down over here thanks for
watching i hope you guys have an awesome
day and again check out that link it's
pinned in the top comment below in this
video peace out
you